This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This past February, the American New Mismatics Association held its annual convention at the Savannah Convention Center in Savannah, Georgia. Good morning. Six o'clock today. For the uninitiated, numismatics is the fancy word for coins and the study of coins. Okay, massive room. There are dozens and dozens and dozens.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年二月，美国钱币协会在佐治亚州萨凡纳市的萨凡纳会议中心举办了年度大会。早上好。现在是六点钟。对于外行来说，“钱币学”（numismatics）是硬币及其研究的华丽称呼。好的，巨大的房间。这里有几十、几十、几十……
and dozens of vendors. And that's reporter and novice numismatist Katie Thornton. This was my first time at a coin show. But right away, I could tell that this convention was not necessarily catering to the merely coin curious. More than anything, this show was for collectors. Mostly of U.S. coins, with each booth featuring something for which there was some kind of small but extremely avid fandom. These gold pieces were made with gold from the California gold rush. We're a specialist in what's called three cents silvers or trimes.
……几十个摊位。那位是记者兼钱币学新手凯蒂·桑顿。这是我第一次参加硬币展。但我立刻就能看出，这次大会并不一定是为了满足那些仅仅对硬币感到好奇的人。最重要的是，这个展会是为收藏家准备的。主要是美国硬币，每个展位都展示着某种虽然小众但极其狂热的收藏品。这些金币是用加州淘金热时期的黄金制成的。我们是所谓的“三美分银币”或“三美分硬币”的专家。
These are half dimes. Have you ever heard of a half dime? I have now. There was also a society dedicated to crushed pennies, like when the machines smush the pennies, or as they call them, elongateds. Why do we stop on pennies? You give me a foreign currency and we'll smash it
这些是半角硬币。你听说过半角硬币吗？我现在听说了。还有一个专门收集压扁便士的协会，就是那种机器把便士压扁后的样子，或者他们称之为“拉长币”。为什么我们要停在便士上？你给我一种外国货币，我们把它压扁……
and see how lovely the design comes out. But Katie wasn't on the hunt for anything quite so niche. Instead, she was in Savannah to learn about what has to be the most widely collected coin in American history. So I'm of the age where my sort of introduction to coin collecting was to state quarters. Do you have any of could show me? Oh, yeah. Of course, everyone in America knows about state quarters. Chances are you have one hiding in your couch cushion right now.
……看看设计出来的效果有多可爱。但凯蒂并不是在寻找如此小众的东西。相反，她来到萨凡纳是为了了解美国历史上收藏最广泛的硬币。我这个年纪的人，对硬币收藏的启蒙就是州纪念25美分硬币。你有可以给我看的吗？哦，当然。当然，每个美国人都知道州纪念25美分硬币。你现在很可能就在沙发垫里藏着一枚。
From 1999 until 2009, the U.S. men issued 56 special quarter designs, one for each state and territory. and Washington, D.C. They put billions of these special quarters into circulation. On the front, you'll see the classic profile of George Washington, but turn any of them over, and you'll see an engraving of something that some state or territory likes about itself. The quarter from my home state of Minnesota features a loon. Kansas has a bison, and Illinois, well, it couldn't decide.
从1999年到2009年，美国铸币局发行了56种特殊的25美分硬币设计，每个州、领地和华盛顿特区各一种。他们将数十亿枚这种特殊硬币投入流通。正面是乔治·华盛顿的经典侧面像，但翻到背面，你会看到某个州或领地引以为傲的事物的雕刻。我家乡明尼苏达州的硬币上有一只潜鸟。堪萨斯州有野牛，而伊利诺伊州嘛，它没法决定。
So it has Lincoln kind of framed by the outline of the state with the Sears Tower in the background. Somewhat awkwardly, two different state quarters featured the Wright Brothers Flyer, because the first modern airplane was built in Ohio, but it was flown in North Carolina. But the state quarters series is more than just a bunch of cool designs on the back of some coins. Yeah, when they first came out, if you were like me, you probably thought, hey, cute, a fun little thing the government did just for the hell of it. But that's just not true.
所以它把林肯像放在州轮廓中，背景是西尔斯大厦。有点尴尬的是，两枚不同的州纪念币都采用了莱特兄弟的飞机，因为第一架现代飞机是在俄亥俄州制造的，但却是在北卡罗来纳州试飞的。但州纪念币系列不仅仅是硬币背面的一些酷炫设计。是的，当它们刚出来时，如果你像我一样，你可能会想，嘿，真可爱，政府随手做的一件有趣的小事。但事实并非如此。
In reality, just beneath its shiny metal surface, the state quarters initiative was a high-stakes government program, one in which coin collecting played a critical role. Because it turns out the mint didn't spend all those years creating billions of new coins just for the sake of civic pride. Instead, the state quarters were developed for the express purpose of getting us to collect them and to turn a healthy profit for the U.S. government. Today, the story of how the U.S. makes money off of making money and how it makes even more if you collect. In many ways, the Mint State Quarters program is the product of a series of innovations in American currency, starting with the invention of the quarter itself, because for the first 200 years of colonial history,
实际上，在闪亮的金属表面之下，州纪念币计划是一项高风险的政府项目，硬币收藏在其中发挥了关键作用。因为事实证明，铸币局并没有花费那么多年时间创造数十亿枚新硬币仅仅是为了公民自豪感。相反，州纪念币的开发明确目的是为了让我们去收藏它们，并为美国政府赚取可观的利润。今天，我们将讲述美国如何通过制造货币来赚钱，以及如果你收藏它，它如何赚得更多。在许多方面，铸币局的州纪念币计划是一系列美国货币创新产物，始于25美分硬币本身的发明，因为在殖民历史的前200年里，
America didn't even have a standard system of denomination. So the earliest coins that were used in the earliest settlements of what, became the United States, were literally the coins that settlers brought in their pockets. Jesse Kraft is an assistant curator at the American numismatic Society, not the American Numismatic Association, which put on the coin show a different numismatic group. And he focuses on American coins. The first boats that came over actually had a lot of German settlers as well. So there's a good mix of German coins, English coins, of course Spanish-American coins. Soon, coins from all over the world made their way into the colonies.
美国甚至没有统一的面额体系。因此，在美国成为美国之前的最早定居点中使用的最早硬币，实际上是定居者口袋里带来的硬币。杰西·克拉夫特是美国钱币学会的助理馆长，不是举办硬币展的美国钱币协会，那是另一个钱币组织。他专注于美国硬币。第一批乘船过来的人中实际上也有很多德国定居者。所以这里有德国硬币、英国硬币，当然还有西班牙-美洲硬币的良好混合。很快，来自世界各地的硬币进入了殖民地。
English shillings, Portuguese Joes, German tollers. It was chaotic. It's not like the exchange rate for these things was one-to-one. But Kraft says there is one thing making it easier. In those days, coins were made almost entirely of rare precious metals like gold or more often silver. That meant that no matter what country the coin was from, its value was determined by its metal content, how much gold or silver was in there. So each piece was weighed to check its gold weight. And because the different coins had different weights and wore down, even just like a little bit of friction on a gold coin would actually affect its value. And if that sounds impractical, well, it often was. Imagine trying to buy a herd of sheep only to find that the precious silver coin you'd had in your satchel this whole time
英国先令、葡萄牙乔、德国塔勒。这很混乱。这些东西的汇率并不是一比一。但克拉夫特说有一件事让它变得更容易。在那个年代，硬币几乎完全由黄金或更常见的白银等稀有贵金属制成。这意味着无论硬币来自哪个国家，其价值都由其金属含量决定，即其中含有多少黄金或白银。所以每一枚硬币都要称重以检查其含金量。而且因为不同的硬币重量不同且会磨损，即使是金币上的一点点摩擦也会影响其价值。如果这听起来不切实际，嗯，它确实经常如此。想象一下，试图购买一群羊，却发现你包里一直装着的珍贵银币……
was too worn down to pay for it all. Complicating things further, there were never enough of the same. these random worn-down coins making their way into the colonies for everyone to use in the first place. So the colonists also had to use something else as money. One of the first pieces of money that was like legislated as legal tender was actually corn. Corn, wheat, and barley were all literally used as money with an exchange rate just like any other currency. In 1631, for example, one bushel of corn had the same spending power as six English shillings.
磨损得太厉害，付不起钱。更复杂的是，这些随机磨损的硬币进入殖民地后，从来都不够每个人使用。所以殖民者还必须使用其他东西作为货币。最早被立法为法定货币的货币之一实际上是玉米。玉米、小麦和大麦确实被用作货币，汇率就像任何其他货币一样。例如，在1631年，一蒲式耳玉米的购买力与六个英国先令相同。
They even accepted corn for payment and taxes. That's how legal it was. Like, this is money. Eventually, though, people got tired of buying their cows with a combination of random European denominations plus a bunch of bulky loose grain. So after the United States won its independence, its leaders finally decided that we might want to make our own standardized monetary system. You know, it's at that point, Jefferson wrote his now famous notes on coinage.
他们甚至接受玉米支付税款。这就是它的合法程度。就像，这就是钱。然而，最终人们厌倦了用各种随机的欧洲面额加上一堆笨重的散装谷物来买牛。因此，在美国赢得独立后，其领导人终于决定我们可能需要建立自己的标准化货币体系。你知道，就在那时，杰斐逊写下了他现在著名的《关于铸币的笔记》。
Oh, yeah, so famous. You know, a very simple name, but it kind of redefined everything. Jefferson basically says, hey, British money is confusing. A pence is one 240th of a pound. A farthing is one 960th. Spanish money, though. It uses easy, common sense fractions. Haves, quarters.
哦，是的，非常出名。你知道，名字很简单，但它重新定义了一切。杰斐逊基本上说，嘿，英国货币太令人困惑了。一便士是英镑的1/240。一法寻是1/960。然而，西班牙货币使用简单、常识性的分数。二分之一，四分之一。
That's what we should do. So in 1792, the U.S. meant began making dollar coins, name for the Spanish dollar as the United States base unit. Just like their Spanish predecessors, dollar coins were made of silver. And early on, the mint made gold coins, too. They were called eagles. That's literally the name of the coin, silver dollars and gold eagles. An eagle was worth $10.
这就是我们应该做的。因此，在1792年，美国铸币局开始制造美元硬币，以西班牙银元命名作为美国的基础单位。就像它们的前身西班牙银元一样，美元硬币也是用白银制成的。早些时候，铸币局也制造金币。它们被称为“鹰币”。这确实是硬币的名字，银元和金鹰币。一枚鹰币价值10美元。
So these are half eagles, these $5 pieces. This is Caroline Turco. She is a curator at the American Numismatic Association. I ran into her at the coin. show in Savannah, where she showed me these old gold coins. So it's based on weight. So the $5 half eagles here are $5 worth of gold, give or take a few cents at that time to consider the amount of work and money it took to make it. And then the smaller ones, they're a quarter eagle, and they are worth of gold. And silver coins worked pretty much the same way, which is to say
所以这些是半鹰币，即5美元的硬币。这是卡罗琳·图尔科。她是美国钱币协会的馆长。我在萨凡纳的硬币展上遇到了她，她向我展示了这些旧金币。所以它是基于重量的。这里的5美元半鹰币价值5美元的黄金，当时考虑到制造它所需的工作量和金钱，会有几美分的误差。然后是较小的那些，它们是四分之一鹰币，它们价值……的黄金。银币的工作原理也差不多，也就是说……
the way they do today. Dollars, half dollars, and of course, quarters. But beyond just standardizing the denominations, the early U.S. Mint faced another equally important numismatic task. It had to decide what our coins would look like. Only, these first designs were nothing like our modern state quarters. Instead of dozens of elaborate variations, early U.S. coins only featured a small number of very simple, some would say, boring motifs, and deliberately so. That's because the mint used design in part to, guard against counterfeiting. By making engravings clean, simple, and consistent, you could easily spot any deviation. One of the reasons why they wanted to keep the design so similar was
它们今天的方式。美元、半美元，当然还有25美分。但除了标准化面额之外，早期的美国铸币局还面临着另一项同样重要的钱币任务。它必须决定我们的硬币长什么样。只是，这些最初的设计与我们现代的州纪念币完全不同。早期美国硬币没有数十种复杂的变体，只有少数非常简单、有些人会说是无聊的主题，而且是刻意为之。这是因为铸币局部分利用设计来防止伪造。通过使雕刻清晰、简单且一致，你可以很容易地发现任何偏差。他们想要保持设计如此相似的原因之一是……
if they all had minor, minor differences, then a counterfeiter could create another coin with a minor difference that would just kind of be accepted. All these counterfeiting countermeasures required that the first U.S. coins all looked pretty much the same. And thanks to our first president, they didn't even have any real faces on them. The first U.S. meant, they go to George Washington and they say, sir, we're going to need your bust to be made so that we can have your face on coins. But he says, absolutely not, because that is for a monarchy. And George is like, we'd literally just fought a war to get rid of our monarch.
如果它们都有微小的差异，那么伪造者就可以制造出另一种带有微小差异的硬币，这种硬币就会被接受。所有这些防伪措施都要求最初的美国硬币看起来都差不多。多亏了我们的第一任总统，它们甚至上面没有任何真实的人脸。最初的美国铸币局，他们去找乔治·华盛顿说，先生，我们需要制作您的半身像，这样我们就可以把您的脸印在硬币上。但他坚决拒绝，因为那是君主制才有的。乔治说，我们刚刚打了一场战争来摆脱我们的君主。
How dare you try to make me into that same symbol? And he said, over my dead body, which, by the way, if you've seen a quarter recently, awkward. But even more than the concern over counterfeiting, or Washington's living body, it was the technology of the time that limited the design of these early coins. Engravers in the 19th century had to carve designs by hand into a tiny steel stamp called a dye using even tinier little chisel tools. They didn't have electric lights, so they were doing this outside or in a window or straining their eyes in candlelight. Then they'd have to either put some metal under the dye and hammer the image onto the coin to be or stamp the design onto the coin with a press powered by human muscle or horses or eventually steam. Not easy.
你怎么敢试图把我变成同样的象征？他说，除非我死，顺便说一句，如果你最近见过25美分硬币，那很尴尬。但比起对伪造的担忧，或者华盛顿的肉身，当时的科技限制了这些早期硬币的设计。19世纪的雕刻师必须使用更小的凿子工具，手工将设计雕刻到一个称为“模具”的微小钢印上。他们没有电灯，所以他们是在户外、窗边，或者在烛光下费力地工作。然后他们必须把金属放在模具下，用锤子把图像敲到硬币上，或者用人力、马力或后来的蒸汽动力压机把设计压在硬币上。不容易。
The first human figure allowed on a U.S. coin was Lady Liberty. But given the technological constraints, the mince engravers quickly discovered there wasn't much you could do with her. Initially, it was mostly her head, her head in profile with flowing hair, Later, her hair was tied up with a ribbon. Eventually, they figured out how to get her whole body on there. But even so, the coin designs from year to year were pretty bland. Until, finally, in 1904, President Theodore Roosevelt said, hey, our coinage is ugly.
美国硬币上允许出现的第一个人物是自由女神。但考虑到技术限制，铸币局的雕刻师很快发现你对她做不了什么。最初，主要是她的头部，侧面轮廓，头发飘逸。后来，她的头发用丝带扎了起来。最终，他们想出了如何把她的全身放上去。但即便如此，每年的硬币设计还是相当平淡。直到1904年，西奥多·罗斯福总统说，嘿，我们的硬币太丑了。
He actually described the design of American coins as atrocious hideousness. He was not playing around. And Theodore Roosevelt was like, I want good stuff again. Luckily, at some point during Teddy's tantrum, he made a specific demand. The U.S. Mint, he urged, should import a near-miraculous new device that had recently been invented in France.
他实际上将美国硬币的设计描述为“极其丑陋”。他不是在开玩笑。西奥多·罗斯福说，我想要好东西。幸运的是，在泰迪发脾气期间，他提出了一个具体要求。他敦促美国铸币局引进一种最近在法国发明的近乎奇迹的新设备。
It was called the Jean-Vierreduction machine. Essentially, you could sculpt a large-sized coin, you know, sometimes two and three feet in diameter, you know, quote-unquote coin, and then you could put this design onto the Jean-Vier reduction machine, and it would have this little stylus and just slowly, slowly go over the design
它被称为让-维尔缩减机。本质上，你可以雕刻一枚大尺寸的硬币，你知道，有时直径两三英尺，你知道，所谓的“硬币”，然后你可以把这个设计放到让-维尔缩减机上，它会有一个小触针，慢慢地、慢慢地经过设计……
and at the same exact time, engrave that design onto a dye the actual size of the coin. Oh, so cool. The Jean-Vier machine allowed the mint to mass-produce coins with a level of detail that would have been impossible before. Suddenly, Lady Liberty could do more things. Starting in the early 1900s, you got Liberty walking towards a rising sun, Liberty ascending a mountain with a capital dome in the background. Liberty with a winged fringian cap with a beautiful column, wrapped in a vining olive plant on the other side.
……同时，将该设计雕刻到与硬币实际大小相同的模具上。哦，太酷了。让-维尔机器使铸币局能够以以前不可能达到的细节水平大规模生产硬币。突然间，自由女神可以做更多的事情了。从20世纪初开始，你有了走向初升太阳的自由女神，有背景是国会大厦圆顶、攀登高山的自由女神。另一面是戴着带翅膀的弗里吉亚帽、有着美丽的柱子、缠绕着藤蔓橄榄植物的自由女神。
This aesthetic revolution in U.S. currency has been termed the American Renaissance of coins. It even led to an explosion in special commemorative coin designs in the 1930s for things like the Texas Centennial and the opening of the Bay Bridge, to the point that the whole thing actually got kind of out of hand. There is one commemorative coin that was made to have a living person on it. It was an Alabama senator. It's Alabama. Why? Why?
这种美国货币的美学革命被称为美国硬币的“文艺复兴”。它甚至导致了20世纪30年代特殊纪念币设计的爆炸式增长，用于德克萨斯百年纪念和海湾大桥开通等事件，以至于整个事情变得有点失控。有一枚纪念币是为了纪念一个活着的人。那是一位阿拉巴马州的参议员。是阿拉巴马州。为什么？为什么？
Because he wanted his face on a coin. But the ability to put almost anything you wanted on a coin was not enough on its own to pave the way for the state quarters program. For that to happen, U.S. coins would need to undergo one more critical transformation, this time to their metal content. Remember, up until this point, silver coins were still made of silver. They had that inherent metal value. But in the 1960s, that ended. President Lyndon Johnson got rid of all of our pretty, shiny silver coins and replaced them with something called clad coins. In clad coinage, a piece of low-cost, kind of ugly metal, is clad in a thin layer of something a little bit prettier.
因为他想把自己的脸印在硬币上。但仅仅能在硬币上放任何你想要的东西，并不足以铺平州纪念币计划的道路。要实现这一点，美国硬币还需要经历另一次关键的转变，这次是关于它们的金属含量。记住，直到这一点，银币仍然是用白银制成的。它们具有固有的金属价值。但在20世纪60年代，这种情况结束了。林登·约翰逊总统取消了我们所有漂亮、闪亮的银币，取而代之的是一种叫做“包层硬币”的东西。在包层硬币中，一块低成本、有点丑的金属被包裹在一层稍微漂亮一点的薄层中。
It's a much cheaper way to make a coin. So in 1965, looking for ways to save money, Johnson convinced Congress to stop putting silver in coins. Instead, he had them minted from copper and then covered in nickel. They were nicknamed Johnson sandwiches. Jesse Kraft says that prior to this, if a national government ever debased its currency, they would only dare to do it very gradually, changing the coins metal content a little at a time over the course of decades. LBJ, God bless them, just went ahead and did it all at once. In 1964, literally all the coins are silver, 1965, none of them are silver.
这是一种制造硬币便宜得多的方法。因此，在1965年，为了寻找省钱的方法，约翰逊说服国会停止在硬币中加入白银。相反，他让他们用铜铸造，然后覆盖上镍。它们被称为“约翰逊三明治”。杰西·克拉夫特说，在此之前，如果一个国家政府要贬低其货币，他们只会非常缓慢地进行，在几十年内一点一点地改变硬币的金属含量。林登·约翰逊，上帝保佑他们，直接一次性完成了。1964年，所有的硬币都是银的；1965年，它们都不是银的。
So it kind of like created valueless coins. So it's actually one of the most significant things that's ever happened since perhaps the beginning of coins themselves. And no one seemed to care. And it's true. No one really cared. Everyone just carried on as if we were all still lugging these little pieces of silver around and continued spending and accepting U.S. coins like nothing had changed. But for the mint, everything had changed. because this strange metallurgical bait and switch meant that suddenly a coin like a quarter costs way less than a quarter to make.
所以它创造了毫无价值的硬币。这实际上是自硬币诞生以来发生的最重要的事情之一。而且似乎没人关心。确实如此。没人真正在意。每个人都像我们还在拖着这些小银片一样继续生活，并继续像什么都没发生一样消费和接受美国硬币。但对于铸币局来说，一切都变了。因为这种奇怪的冶金诱饵和转换意味着像25美分这样的硬币制造成本突然远低于25美分。
And that discrepancy between the production cost of the coin and its face value allowed the meant to engage in a money-making scheme beloved by governments the world over. It's called seniorage. Okay, seniorage. It's really a simple concept. This is Philip Deal. These days, he's the president of U.S. Money Reserve, a coin's. seller. A few decades ago, though, he was director of the U.S. Mint. And he says, to understand seniorage, you have to think of the Mint as a business, a business whose product is coins.
硬币的生产成本与其面值之间的差异使铸币局能够参与一种深受世界各国政府喜爱的赚钱计划。这被称为“铸币税”（seniorage）。好的，铸币税。这真的是一个简单的概念。这是菲利普·迪尔。如今，他是美国货币储备公司的总裁，一家硬币销售商。不过，几十年前，他是美国铸币局局长。他说，要理解铸币税，你必须把铸币局看作一家企业，一家产品是硬币的企业。
And that is, like any product in business, you hope to produce it at a cost that is less than what you sell it for. So the goal for the mint is to make coins as cheaply as possible, but to still sell them at their face value so that they can turn a profit, just like any other product. And when you do that with coins, that's called seniorage. So seniorage is the profit the mint makes from selling a coin for more than a cost to produce it. Like Philip said, simple. Now, if you're wondering who would be stupid enough to pay 25 cents for a coin that only costs a few cents to make, well, you are. And me too.
就像商业中的任何产品一样，你希望以低于售价的成本生产它。因此，铸币局的目标是尽可能便宜地制造硬币，但仍以其面值出售，以便他们可以获利，就像任何其他产品一样。当你用硬币这样做时，这就叫铸币税。所以铸币税是铸币局通过以高于生产成本的价格出售硬币而获得的利润。就像菲利普说的，很简单。现在，如果你想知道谁会傻到花25美分去买一枚制造成本只有几美分的硬币，嗯，就是你。还有我。
And me. We all end up paying full face value for these coins, thanks to a chain of sale that starts with the Mint's largest customer. the independent Federal Reserve Bank. Which, just for clarity, operates independently of the federal government. The Federal Reserve, they pay us, the face value of the coin, and then those coins are distributed to the regional Federal Reserve banks, and the regional Federal Reserve banks then take orders from the banking system in the United States, and the coins are delivered to the banks.
还有我。我们最终都为这些硬币支付了全额面值，这要归功于从铸币局最大的客户——独立的联邦储备银行开始的销售链。顺便说明一下，它独立于联邦政府运作。美联储向我们支付硬币的面值，然后这些硬币被分发到地区联邦储备银行，地区联邦储备银行随后接受美国银行系统的订单，硬币被运送到银行。
Let me translate, at the risk of making this part, a little too simple. The mint makes coins, again, let's say quarters, as cheaply as it can. The banks then buy those quarters at face value from the mint. Businesses buy quarters at face value from banks. And when we get change from the cash registers at those businesses, we get those quarters. So everyone in that sequence, banks, businesses, people, pay 25 cents for something that the mint originally made for much, much less. Once a quarter gets old and worn out, the U.S. government can end up buying it, back and recycling the metal. But that can take a long time. And that coin might have circulated
让我翻译一下，冒着把这部分说得太简单的风险。铸币局尽可能便宜地制造硬币，比如25美分。银行然后以面值从铸币局购买这些25美分。企业以面值从银行购买25美分。当我们从这些企业的收银台找零时，我们得到了这些25美分。所以这个序列中的每个人——银行、企业、个人——都为铸币局最初以低得多的成本制造的东西支付了25美分。一旦25美分硬币变旧磨损，美国政府最终可以买回并回收金属。但这可能需要很长时间。那枚硬币可能已经流通了……
for 30 years. And so for us, the mint, that coin is basically like a 30-year long-term loan, interest-free. So in the end, the only one turning a profit is the U.S. government. But the truth is, this approach only worked well for a little while. When the U.S. first started making significant seniorage off of coins in the 1960s, it was a good bet. The difference between the production cost and the sales price ensured that the mint made about four and a half cents off of every nickel, nine and a half cents off of every dime, and 24 cents off of every quarter. Even the penny made a little bit of money. But as the price of metals like copper rose, so did the cost of making coins. As early as 1974, the cost of making the penny was already approaching its face value.
30年。所以对我们铸币局来说，那枚硬币基本上就像一笔30年的长期无息贷款。所以最终，唯一获利的是美国政府。但事实是，这种方法只在短时间内有效。当美国在20世纪60年代首次从硬币中获得大量铸币税时，这是一个不错的赌注。生产成本和销售价格之间的差异确保了铸币局每枚镍币赚取约4.5美分，每枚角币赚取9.5美分，每枚25美分硬币赚取24美分。即使是便士也赚了一点钱。但随着铜等金属价格的上涨，制造硬币的成本也随之上升。早在1974年，制造便士的成本就已经接近其面值。
So the mint futzed with the metal ratios again, just trying to make this thing for even cheaper. They up to the zinc and lowered the copper, which again worked at first, but not for long. So when Philip Deal became the director of the U.S. Mint in 1994, one of his main goals was to stop and ideally reverse this decline. And so when I was directing, the MET, 30 years ago, I was the first MENT director to recommend the elimination of the penny, and it was long overdue then. Unfortunately, Philip did not have the necessary sway to kill the penny. America would have to wait for someone else to make that one happen.
所以铸币局再次调整了金属比例，试图以更便宜的价格制造这种东西。他们增加了锌，减少了铜，这起初确实有效，但没持续多久。因此，当菲利普·迪尔在1994年成为美国铸币局局长时，他的主要目标之一是停止并理想地扭转这种下降趋势。所以当我在30年前指导铸币局时，我是第一位建议取消便士的局长，当时已经早该取消了。不幸的是，菲利普没有必要的权力来废除便士。美国将不得不等待其他人来实现这一点。
But there was another more exciting idea to boost senior edge that was being bounced around the mint at the same time. A scheme to increase the sales of one of their biggest earners. the quarter. And after a couple years, I started thinking about whether or not it was possible, and I became convinced we could do it. At that time, in the mid-90s, every quarter, thanks to its high face value, was still netting the mint about 22 cents in senior age. And every year, some of those quarters would fall out of circulation. People lost them, accidentally threw them out, or put them in coin jars in the car, which meant every year the banks had to ask the mint for more quarters
但当时铸币局还在酝酿另一个更令人兴奋的增加铸币税的想法。一个增加他们最大收入来源之一——25美分硬币销售额的计划。几年后，我开始思考这是否可能，我确信我们可以做到。那时，在90年代中期，每一枚25美分硬币，由于其高面值，仍然为铸币局带来约22美分的铸币税。每年，其中一些25美分硬币会退出流通。人们丢失了它们，不小心扔掉了它们，或者把它们放在车里的硬币罐里，这意味着每年银行都必须向铸币局要求更多的25美分硬币……
to replace all those missing coins, make up the gap, and ensure that the country didn't run out of change. That, of course, was good for the U.S. government, because selling more quarters to the banks generated more seniorage for the mint. But what if there was a way to get people to take even more quarters out of circulation every year? Well, one way was to convince people to start collecting them. Only, the mint couldn't just rely on hardcore collectors, like the ones I met at the convention to get the job done. The idea was to take billions of dollars worth of quarters out of circulation. If it was ever going to do that, the mint would somehow have to convince ordinary people, people who rarely even thought about quarters, to start collecting them too. And what better way
来替换所有那些丢失的硬币，弥补缺口，并确保国家不会用完零钱。这当然对美国政府有利，因为向银行出售更多的25美分硬币为铸币局产生了更多的铸币税。但如果有一种方法能让人们每年从流通中取出更多的25美分硬币呢？嗯，一种方法是说服人们开始收藏它们。只是，铸币局不能仅仅依靠我在大会上遇到的那些硬核收藏家来完成这项工作。这个想法是从流通中取出价值数十亿美元的25美分硬币。如果它真的要做到这一点，铸币局必须以某种方式说服普通人，那些很少想到25美分硬币的人，也开始收藏它们。还有什么比这更好的方法呢……
to encourage ordinary Americans who start collecting quarters than by issuing a bunch of special designs, say 50 of them. And so I'm sort of famous there for having created the 50 state quarters program. Sneaky, perhaps. Elaborate? Sure. Profitable. Definitely. The idea had been circling among coin fans for years. Canada's mint had already done something similar, and it made money. But Philip couldn't just order the mint to make a bunch of new designs. After all, the Mint, by this point, had been stamping quarters with the same design of George Washington in profile since 1932. Making lots of new designs required lots more resources. To make the state quarters program happen, the Mint needed an advocate in Washington.
鼓励普通美国人开始收藏25美分硬币，那就是发行一堆特殊设计，比如50种。所以，我因为创造了50州纪念币计划而闻名。狡猾吗？也许。精心策划？当然。有利可图？绝对。这个想法在硬币爱好者中已经流传多年。加拿大铸币局已经做过类似的事情，而且赚了钱。但菲利普不能仅仅命令铸币局制造一堆新设计。毕竟，到那时为止，铸币局自1932年以来一直用同样的乔治·华盛顿侧面像来压印25美分硬币。制造大量新设计需要更多的资源。为了实现州纪念币计划，铸币局需要在华盛顿有一个倡导者。
So Philip went to a congressman from Delaware named Mike Castle and laid out his idea. I said, now, this has tremendous education potential. Each one of the 50 states will have designs emblematic of the state. People in the state and the end, students will become excited about it. Philip told him there was no way they could do all these coins in one year. He was thinking they'd roll them out five a year for a decade. But he didn't just want to release them alphabetically. That's boring. We're not teaching anybody anything.
所以菲利普去找了一位来自特拉华州的国会议员迈克·卡斯尔，并提出了他的想法。我说，现在，这具有巨大的教育潜力。50个州中的每一个都将拥有象征该州的设计。州内的人们，最终，学生们会对此感到兴奋。菲利普告诉他，他们不可能在一年内完成所有这些硬币。他想的是十年内每年推出五枚。但他不想只是按字母顺序发布它们。那太无聊了。我们什么也没教给任何人。
Instead, Philip suggested to the congressman from Delaware that they released the coins in the order that the states ratified the Constitution. And it just so happened that Delaware is the first state. And I knew that I could sell him on that with that line. And man, he bought. And he became such a champion of that. And I needed a champion. The Mint needed the Treasury's approval,
相反，菲利普向特拉华州的国会议员建议，他们按照各州批准宪法的顺序发布硬币。碰巧特拉华州是第一个州。我知道我可以用那句话说服他。天哪，他买账了。他成为了那个计划的拥护者。我需要一个拥护者。铸币局需要财政部的批准，
and the Treasury at the time did not like the idea. Too many things could go wrong. They wanted a study done. Everybody in Washington knows that studies are designed to kill proposals. It's just always. So the Treasury ran some numbers. Philip and his colleagues did too, how much seniorage each quarter would net the government, and also how many additional quarters they would get to sell to the banks
而当时的财政部不喜欢这个主意。太多的事情可能会出错。他们想要进行一项研究。华盛顿的每个人都知道，研究旨在扼杀提案。总是这样。所以财政部运行了一些数字。菲利普和他的同事们也做了，每枚25美分硬币将为政府带来多少铸币税，以及他们将额外向银行出售多少25美分硬币……
due to people collecting them and taking them out of circulation. We looked at what's going to be the incremental increase in demand for quarters from people who want to pull them out of circulation and collect them. And the models came up with a range of 2.6 billion to 3.5 billion. In other words, the amount of quarters people took out and kept in their private collection would generate the government at least $2.6 billion in profit.
因为人们收藏它们并将它们从流通中取出。我们研究了那些想要将它们从流通中取出并收藏的人对25美分硬币的需求将会有多大的增量增长。模型得出的范围是26亿到35亿。换句话说，人们取出并保留在私人收藏中的25美分硬币数量将为政府带来至少26亿美元的利润。
And the Treasury ended up recommending the program. And man, as the deputy secretary, I was at that meeting, Deputy Secretary of the Treasury was hot when his hand-picked committee made that recommendation. Congress gave the meant the go-ahead in late 1997, and just over a year later in 1999, the state quarters went live. Hi-ho, Kermit the Frog here, announcing the new 50 state quarters from the United States men. We employed Kermit the Frog.
财政部最终推荐了这个项目。天哪，作为副部长，我在那次会议上，当他亲自挑选的委员会做出那个建议时，财政部副部长很生气。国会在1997年底给了铸币局绿灯，一年多后的1999年，州纪念币上线了。嗨，我是科米蛙，宣布美国铸币局发行新的50州纪念币。我们雇用了科米蛙。
I wanted Kermit because he was the perfect spokes frog for our product, because the appeal was so broad. Each quarter tells something about the state it represents. This one's New Jersey. It was the first time in decades that there was any significant change made to a U.S. coin. And it was exciting. Incredible bus.
我想要科米蛙，因为它是我们产品的完美代言蛙，因为吸引力非常广泛。每枚25美分硬币都讲述了它所代表的州的一些情况。这是新泽西州的。这是几十年来美国硬币首次发生任何重大变化。这令人兴奋。令人难以置信的轰动。
50 state quarters from the United States men. The most exciting change America's ever seen. Philip and his team had done their research. They knew people loved the treasure hunt aspect of collecting. So they worked the... that into the program. All U.S. coins have mint marks, little letters on the front, indicating at which meant the coin was made.
美国铸币局发行的50州纪念币。美国见过的最令人兴奋的变化。菲利普和他的团队做了研究。他们知道人们喜欢收藏的寻宝方面。所以他们把这一点融入了计划中。所有美国硬币都有铸币标记，正面有小字母，表明硬币是在哪个铸币厂制造的。
So they made sure every state quarter bore one of two mint marks, P for the Philadelphia mint, or D for Denver, so people would have twice as many coins to collect. The states especially loved it. Governors got their constituents involved, submitting design concepts and voting on their favorites. And that was a brilliant. marketing move because you got all this free, earn publicity as each state's coin was coming up for production and people would anxiously await the coins release.
所以他们确保每枚州纪念币都带有两个铸币标记之一，费城铸币厂的P或丹佛的D，这样人们就有两倍的硬币可以收集。各州特别喜欢它。州长们让他们的选民参与进来，提交设计概念并投票选出他们最喜欢的。这是一个绝妙的营销举措，因为随着每个州的硬币即将投入生产，你获得了所有这些免费的、赚来的宣传，人们会焦急地等待硬币的发布。
That is true. If you were around when the state quarters first debuted, like I was, you will remember this. They were like the weather. Everyone talked about them all the time. Everyone. Kids loved it. Their parents loved it. We figured teenagers weren't cared a bit.
这是真的。如果你像我一样在州纪念币刚亮相时就在那里，你会记得这一点。它们就像天气一样。每个人都在谈论它们。每个人。孩子们喜欢它。他们的父母喜欢它。我们以为青少年根本不在乎。
I mean, you know, we were competing with computer games. You know, how can coins compete with that? Hugely successful with teenagers, too. In fact, I remember standing in lines of music concerts or restaurants and being around teenagers and young 20-year-olds who'd be talking about the corners. And at times it seemed like almost everyone collected them, or at least would hold on to a few of their favorites.
我的意思是，你知道，我们在和电脑游戏竞争。你知道，硬币怎么能和那个竞争呢？在青少年中也非常成功。事实上，我记得站在音乐会或餐馆的队伍里，周围是谈论硬币的青少年和20岁出头的年轻人。有时似乎几乎每个人都在收集它们，或者至少会保留一些他们最喜欢的。
To this day, loath to part with a Connecticut quarter. I mean, have you seen this thing? It is gorgeous. Soon, the private market was cashing in on it, too, selling all sorts of accessories. Are you like me and my family collecting the new U.S. quarters? Problem is, where do you put them? It's the USA Coin Collection album.
直到今天，我还不舍得把康涅狄格州的25美分硬币分出去。我的意思是，你见过这个东西吗？它太美了。很快，私人市场也从中获利，销售各种配件。你像我和我的家人一样在收集新的美国25美分硬币吗？问题是，你把它们放在哪里？这是美国硬币收藏册。
You'll receive this unique map, which features a space to hold each quarter. Now you can have the perfect way to proudly display your collection with the America's 50 state quarters wooden frame. Due to overwhelming demand for these quarters, this is a limited offer for a limited time. You must act now. But wait, order within the next 10 minutes and will include a special bonus, our 50-state faxbook, filled with exciting information about each day. Call now.
你将收到这张独特的地图，它有一个空间可以容纳每一枚25美分硬币。现在，你可以用美国50州纪念币木框以完美的方式自豪地展示你的收藏。由于对这些硬币的需求巨大，这是一个限时限量优惠。你必须现在行动。但等等，在接下来的10分钟内订购，我们将包括一份特别奖励，我们的50州事实手册，里面充满了关于每一天的令人兴奋的信息。现在就打电话。
As planned, the coins rolled out five a year for 10 years. They made nearly 35 billion of these quarters. Sadly, a stack of 35 billion quarters is not tall enough to reach the moon. We checked. Sorry. You're just going to imagine a lot of quarters. The program was so popular that after a decade of releases, the Mint extended the run an extra year and added the territories.
按照计划，硬币在10年内每年推出5枚。他们制造了近350亿枚这样的25美分硬币。可悲的是，350亿枚25美分硬币堆起来的高度不足以到达月球。我们检查过了。抱歉。你只能想象大量的25美分硬币。这个项目非常受欢迎，以至于在十年的发行后，铸币局将运行时间延长了一年，并增加了领地。
By the end, so many quarters had gone out of circulation that the banking system had to purchase more than twice as many quarters as it had in the 10 years before the initiative. That increase in demand netted the Mint by conservative estimates $2.6 billion, just as Phillips' team had originally predicted. Am I understanding correctly that that was from the senior age alone? Yes. Wow.
到最后，如此多的25美分硬币退出了流通，以至于银行系统不得不购买的25美分硬币数量是该计划实施前10年的两倍多。需求的增加为铸币局带来了保守估计26亿美元的收入，正如菲利普团队最初预测的那样。我理解正确吗，这仅仅是来自铸币税？是的。哇。
Those quarters, those circulating quarters, were in huge demand and were taken out of circulation, and that's where that $2.6 billion come from. That money went back into the Treasury's General Fund, which went to lowering the tax burden and paying down the national debt. It was a huge victory, and it turned a whole generation onto the magic of coins. including Caroline Turco. I remember, like, when the state quarters came out. I was interested for the very first time.
那些25美分硬币，那些流通中的25美分硬币，需求量巨大，并被从流通中取出，这就是那26亿美元的来源。这笔钱回到了财政部的普通基金，用于减轻税收负担和偿还国债。这是一场巨大的胜利，它让整整一代人迷上了硬币的魔力。包括卡罗琳·图尔科。我记得，当州纪念币出来时。我第一次产生了兴趣。
And, you know, here in this show, this is my sixth show, and I've never seen the U.S. meant this busy. Never. In the past year, coins have been in the headlines. The U.S. finally stopped producing the penny, RIP. We have new coin designs that honor the U.S.'s 250th. Coins whose images paint a very specific and perhaps overly generous view of early American history, with designs of pilgrims and the Mayflower.
而且，你知道，在这个展会上，这是我的第六次展会，我从未见过美国铸币局如此忙碌。从来没有。在过去的一年里，硬币登上了头条。美国终于停止了生产便士，安息吧。我们有新的硬币设计来纪念美国建国250周年。这些硬币的图像描绘了对早期美国历史非常具体且可能过于慷慨的看法，设计中有朝圣者和五月花号。
But these coins will be around for a long time, and love them or hate them, they are probably going to get some folks hooked on coin collecting. That's good for the mint, but they're not the only ones who want to see the hobby live on. Every year, the A&A, who puts on the coin show, encourages collectors to do the apparent opposite of what the mint intended, and put some of the more unusual coins back into circulation. But really, it's just their own way of piquing people's interest. If you ever come across an old Standing Liberty Quarter or a wheat penny,
但这些硬币会存在很长时间，无论你喜欢还是讨厌它们，它们很可能会让一些人迷上硬币收藏。这对铸币局有好处，但他们并不是唯一希望看到这种爱好延续下去的人。每年，举办硬币展的美国钱币协会都会鼓励收藏家做与铸币局意图完全相反的事情，并将一些更不寻常的硬币放回流通中。但这实际上只是他们激发人们兴趣的一种方式。如果你偶然发现一枚旧的站姿自由女神25美分硬币或小麦便士，
there's a good chance you have a collector to thank for it, at which point you get to decide. What's this coin worth to you? Ultimately, the state quarters program did something similar, just on a much bigger scale. It got so many of us feeling sentimental about these little hunks of copper and nickel, not just the coin nerds. I didn't have a set of state quarters, but my neighbor did.
你很有可能要感谢一位收藏家，届时你可以决定。这枚硬币对你来说值多少钱？最终，州纪念币计划做了类似的事情，只是规模更大。它让我们中的许多人对这些小块铜镍产生了感情，不仅仅是硬币极客。我没有一套州纪念币，但我的邻居有。
He had a book and everything. And when I found a state quarter, I'd gasp, put it in my pocket, and run over to Andy's house to see if he had Wisconsin yet. He always had Wisconsin. He always had whatever I found. But together, we took plenty of quarters out of circulation. The state quarters turned us all into numismatists. It put the collecting bug in all of us, at least a little bit.
他有一本书和所有东西。当我找到一枚州纪念币时，我会倒吸一口凉气，把它放进口袋，跑到安迪家看看他是否已经有了威斯康星州。他总是有威斯康星州。他总是有我找到的任何东西。但我们一起从流通中取出了大量的25美分硬币。州纪念币把我们都变成了钱币学家。它让我们所有人都感染了收藏病毒，至少有一点点。
So when I was in Savannah, I bought a coin. Minted just a stones throw away from beautiful uptown, Oakland, California. It's an S. San Francisco mint quarter. So it's never been in circulation. I've learned in the coin world that when people say it's in mint condition, they mean it literally. Like, someone got this from the mint, and it never made the rounds. This one was made in 1951. That means it's almost all silver, and it has this really nice, bright sheen.
所以当我在萨凡纳时，我买了一枚硬币。铸造地点离美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心仅一箭之遥。这是一枚S标记的旧金山铸币厂25美分硬币。所以它从未进入流通。我在硬币世界里学到，当人们说它处于“造币厂状态”（mint condition）时，他们是字面意思。就像，有人从铸币厂得到了这个，它从未流通。这枚是1951年制造的。这意味着它几乎全是银的，而且它有一种非常漂亮、明亮的光泽。
But if you just glanced at this coin casually, there's a good chance you wouldn't think anything of it. I wouldn't have, just a few months ago. I think I'd like to get this never circulated one from 1951. Okay. Okay. I got this quarter for $20. That's $4 over the intrinsic value, $19.75 over the face value. But I'm not planning on holding on. to it for long. Call me a sucker, but I think this coin, this little piece of history, deserves to
但如果你只是随意看一眼这枚硬币，你很有可能不会想到什么。几个月前我不会。我想我想要这枚1951年从未流通过的硬币。好的。好的。我花了20美元买了这枚25美分硬币。这比内在价值高出4美元，比面值高出19.75美元。但我没打算持有它太久。叫我傻瓜吧，但我认为这枚硬币，这枚小小的历史片段，值得……
be out in the wild. You're going to put it in circulation? I'm thinking I might. Okay. Just to see if, to just think about somebody picking it up down the line. Absolutely. That's cool. Okay, let's do it. All right. Funny question, but do you take cash? When we return, the story of one state quarter that might not have been worth it. So we're back with Katie Thornton. Hey, Katie? Hey, Rauman. So we talked about how the state quarters program works and how they made money for the government. But I hear you have a story about the design of the quarters. Yes, I have a story of an adventure or maybe a misadventure in state quarter design. But before we get there, I want to just look at all the quarter designs really quick. I send you a link that has all of the special quarters. Yes. Okay, I see them all arrayed in front of me, all 50. 56. 56. 56.
流传到市面上。你要把它投入流通吗？我在考虑。好的。只是为了看看，只是想一下以后有人捡到它会怎样。当然。那太酷了。好吧，我们开始吧。好的。一个有趣的问题，你们收现金吗？稍后回来，我们将讲述一枚可能不值得这样做的州纪念币的故事。我们又回到了凯蒂·桑顿的节目。嘿，凯蒂？嘿，罗曼。我们谈到了州纪念币计划是如何运作的，以及它们是如何为政府赚钱的。但我听说你有一个关于纪念币设计的故事。是的，我有一个关于州纪念币设计的冒险故事，或者说是一次不幸的经历。但在进入正题之前，我想快速浏览一下所有的纪念币设计。我发给你一个包含所有特殊纪念币的链接。是的。好的，我看到它们都排列在我面前，一共50枚。56枚。56枚。56枚。
56. Don't forget DC and the territories. We've got them all. So if you open them up, I mean, do any stick out to you? Let's see. I like the bison on Kansas quite a bit. I like the bison, one strong image. Yeah, yeah.
56枚。别忘了华盛顿特区和各领地。我们都有。那么，如果你把它们打开，我的意思是，有没有哪一枚让你印象深刻？让我看看。我挺喜欢堪萨斯州那枚上面的野牛。我喜欢野牛，一个强有力的形象。是的，是的。
It's clear that the ones that work the best are kind of trying to put together one cohesive image. Like Florida has like a ship and like the space shuttle and some palm trees and stuff. it just looks like a weird patchwork of clip art, you know, and that that is not doing it for me. Yeah, I agree. And I think it sort of makes me think about flag design a little bit in that, you know, you want to sort of strive for cleanness and simplicity, sort of like communicating a clear message in as few images as you can. Yeah, no, I think that there's some similarities. I think the differences are that, you know, quarters are meant to be enjoyed, you know, looking at up close. Engraving is a real fine, detailed art form. So, yeah, I'm open to these being much more complicated. I do like them to have a kind of cohesive, I don't know, composition and feel to them. I think that's the main thing. But like there's just something about them that's just lovely.
很明显，效果最好的那些设计是试图将一个连贯的形象组合在一起。比如佛罗里达州的那枚，上面有一艘船、航天飞机和一些棕榈树之类的东西。它看起来就像是一堆奇怪的剪贴画拼凑在一起，你知道，这对我来说没什么吸引力。是的，我同意。而且我认为这让我联想到旗帜设计，你知道，你想要追求简洁和简单，就像用尽可能少的图像传达一个清晰的信息。是的，不，我认为它们有一些相似之处。我认为不同之处在于，你知道，纪念币是用来近距离欣赏的。雕刻是一门非常精细、细腻的艺术形式。所以，是的，我不介意它们变得更复杂。我确实希望它们有一种连贯的、我不知道，构图和感觉。我认为这是最重要的事情。但它们身上确实有一种令人喜爱的东西。
I agree. Yeah. But Roman, I wanted to tell you about one person who I interviewed who really did not like the design of one of these quarters. Missouri. Missouri. Okay. Okay. Let me pull up Missouri and see if I can get a gander of Missouri. Yeah, for those of us who are not, you know, familiar with the design of the Missouri State Quarter, will you give us a little description? Yeah, sure. It has the Gateway Arch there and it has trees. So there's sort of anachronistic combination of the arch and trees.
我同意。是的。但是罗曼，我想告诉你我采访过的一个人，他真的很不喜欢其中一枚纪念币的设计。密苏里州。密苏里州。好的。好的，让我调出密苏里州的纪念币，看看我能不能一睹它的风采。是的，对于我们这些不熟悉密苏里州州纪念币设计的人，你能给我们简单描述一下吗？好的，没问题。上面有大拱门，还有树。所以这是一种拱门和树木的时代错误组合。
And it looks like a depiction of the Lewis and Clark Expedition. So it looks like that's kind of their claim to fame with this quarter is the beginning of the Lewis and Clark Expedition. Yeah, right. So it's sort of like a handful of different things that are iconically Missouri. Yeah, it's definitely not like hideous. No. But the person who was really upset about this coin design was the artist who submitted the original design concept. His name is Paul Jackson, and he's a well-known watercolor painter in Columbia, Missouri.
它看起来像是刘易斯和克拉克远征队的写照。所以看起来这就是这枚纪念币的成名之处，即刘易斯和克拉克远征的开始。是的，没错。所以它有点像是一堆具有密苏里州标志性的东西。是的，它绝对不算丑陋。不。但真正对这个硬币设计感到不满的人是提交原始设计概念的艺术家。他的名字叫保罗·杰克逊，他是密苏里州哥伦比亚市一位著名的水彩画家。
And here's how he describes that coin. My original design was sort of an elegant symbol. It had two people in a canoe, and it had the arch, you know, sort of fading into the mist in the background. I mean, that sounds like in the spirit of what we're looking at. So what is the problem? Like, what did they change that he doesn't like? Well, yeah, I mean, the overall design concept stayed the same. But Paul says the devil is in the details.
这就是他描述那枚硬币的方式。我最初的设计是一种优雅的象征。它有两个人坐在独木舟里，还有拱门，你知道，在背景中逐渐消失在雾中。我的意思是，这听起来符合我们所看到的精神。那么问题出在哪里？他们改变了什么让他不喜欢？嗯，是的，总体的设计概念保持不变。但保罗说，魔鬼藏在细节里。
Like, take the arch, for example. In the U.S. Mint's version, it looks like it's crossing the river from Illinois to Missouri. And it's shaped like a McDonald's French fry bent over. It's very misshapen. Well, I mean, it looks like an arch. But maybe it's not a factually accurate arch. I could understand this is like the issues with defecting things on coins, but does he have other issues with the design? Yes, he certainly does.
比如，以拱门为例。在美国铸币局的版本中，它看起来像是从伊利诺伊州跨越河流到密苏里州。而且它的形状像一根弯曲的麦当劳薯条。它非常畸形。嗯，我的意思是，它看起来像个拱门。但也许它不是一个事实准确的拱门。我能理解这是硬币描绘事物时出现的问题，但他对设计还有其他意见吗？是的，他当然有。
Instead of two guys in a canoe, it had three, Larry Moe and Curley. They're going downhill upriver and the arch crosses the river from Illinois to Missouri, plus the trees are made of broccoli. Plus the trees are made of broccoli. Okay, so he doesn't like the way the trees are drawn, which I, When you say that they look like broccoli, they do look like broccoli. I can see what he's talking about. So, you know, how did these changes get included into the final design based off of his original painting? Yeah, so Paul submitted his original design for the Missouri State Quarter contest to the First Lady's Office, which was running the competition back in 2001.
除了独木舟里的两个人，变成了三个，拉里、莫和库里。他们顺流而下，拱门从伊利诺伊州跨越河流到密苏里州，而且树木看起来像西兰花。而且树木看起来像西兰花。好吧，所以他不喜欢树木的画法，而我，当你提到它们看起来像西兰花时，它们确实看起来像西兰花。我明白他在说什么了。那么，这些变化是如何根据他最初的画作被纳入最终设计的呢？是的，所以保罗为密苏里州州纪念币竞赛提交了他最初的设计，提交给了当时负责比赛的第一夫人办公室，那是在2001年。
He had collected coins as a kid, and he thought his design would be a cool way to honor the bicentennial of the Lewis and Clark expedition. So he was really stoked when he won. And for a while, not much happened. He says he didn't hear anything. But then in the spring of the following year, he got a message. I got the first email from someone in Georgia saying, what do you think about what the U.S. Mint did to your state quarter design? And at that point, I had no idea.
他小时候收集过硬币，他认为他的设计将是纪念刘易斯和克拉克远征二百周年的一种很酷的方式。所以当他获胜时，他非常激动。有一段时间，什么也没发生。他说他没有听到任何消息。但后来在第二年春天，他收到了一条信息。我收到了来自佐治亚州某人的第一封电子邮件，说，你觉得美国铸币局对你的州纪念币设计做了什么？在那一刻，我一无所知。
I didn't know what the U.S. Mint had done to my state quarter design. The Mint's design looked kind of like Paul's, but Paul and others thought it was. just really ugly. There was clearly something wrong. They dumbed it down to the point where it was unacceptable. It was just unusable. And they misspelled the word bicentennial. Well, they must have fixed that, right? I would hope so, but they did eventually just get rid of that word altogether. Well, good. Did they offer any explanation as to why the design changed and like, you know, what the redesign process was like?
我不知道美国铸币局对我的州纪念币设计做了什么。铸币局的设计看起来有点像保罗的，但保罗和其他人认为它真的很丑。显然出了什么问题。他们把它简化到了不可接受的地步。它简直无法使用。而且他们把“二百周年”这个词拼错了。好吧，他们肯定修正了那个，对吧？我希望如此，但他们最终确实完全去掉了那个词。好吧，很好。他们有没有解释为什么设计会改变，以及重新设计的过程是怎样的？
Yeah, you know, Paul says he didn't get much from them. The mint said it was uncoignable, and they said that Paul didn't understand like metal flow and things like this. Sure. And I guess multiple private mints who make, you know, special tokens and things like that reached out to him and they were like, oh, this is coinable. We would love to make it. Huh. Huh. But Paul says, you know, from the mint, they just sort of sprung these design changes on him. Wow. Paul doesn't seem like he was a person that was going to let this go. No, he was not going to let this go. He was not going down without a fight. So I gathered a few of my supporters and went to protest. And so I put out the call on AOL and invited anybody who was upset about it to join me at the state capital.
是的，你知道，保罗说他从他们那里没得到什么信息。铸币局说它“无法铸造”，他们说保罗不懂金属流动之类的东西。当然。而且我猜有几家制造特殊代币之类的私人铸币厂联系了他，他们说，哦，这是可以铸造的。我们很乐意制作它。嗯。嗯。但保罗说，你知道，铸币局只是把这些设计变更强加给了他。哇。保罗看起来不像是一个会轻易放弃的人。不，他不会轻易放弃。他不会不战而降。所以我召集了一些支持者去抗议。我在AOL上发出了号召，邀请任何对此感到不满的人在州议会大厦加入我。
And about 50 people showed up. They all had little signs. The U.S. meant lied. They've stolen state pride, things like that. I mean, I love this scene so much. But did the protests actually accomplish anything? Well, it would have been a dud because what Paul didn't realize was that the state legislature wasn't actually in session at the time. But one thing that Paul did at this protest was he took about 20 quarters, just normal quarters, because at this point, the Missouri state quarter hadn't actually come out yet. They'd just been publicizing the design. And he printed up some round stickers with his Missouri quarter design on it.
大约有50人出现了。他们都拿着小标语。美国铸币局撒谎了。他们窃取了州的骄傲，诸如此类。我的意思是，我非常喜欢这个场景。但抗议真的取得了什么成果吗？嗯，这本来会是一场闹剧，因为保罗没有意识到州议会当时并没有开会。但保罗在这次抗议中做的一件事是，他拿了大约20枚硬币，只是普通的硬币，因为当时密苏里州州纪念币还没有发行。他们只是公布了设计。他打印了一些圆形的贴纸，上面印着他的密苏里州纪念币设计。
and he stuck it on the tailside of these 20 or so quarters. And the next morning, I was dead asleep and got a phone call from somebody at the Kansas City Star. And this reporter said, how does it feel to be under Secret Service investigation for defacing money? And the first word out of my mouth was awesome. That's how you felt? Yep. Because I knew at that moment we had gotten traction. So I printed 250,000 more stickers.
他把贴纸贴在了这20枚左右硬币的背面。第二天早上，我睡得正死，接到了堪萨斯城星报某人的电话。这位记者说，因为损毁货币而受到特勤局调查，感觉如何？我脱口而出的第一个词是“太棒了”。你当时是这种感觉？是的。因为我知道那一刻我们已经引起了关注。所以我又打印了25万张贴纸。
And I put them on the back of 250,000 quarters. Whoa. Really? I mean, that's Paul's telling of it. That's more than $60,000 in quarters. Yeah. He said sometimes they would just go to the bank and get rolls of quarters and sticker them up and then return them to the bank. Amazing.
我把它们贴在了25万枚硬币的背面。哇。真的吗？我的意思是，这是保罗的说法。那可是超过6万美元的硬币。是的。他说有时他们会直接去银行拿成卷的硬币，贴上贴纸，然后再把它们还给银行。太神奇了。
I mean, he's like, there's quite a lot of dedication here. But he didn't just return them all to the bank. Like, he would also use them to sort of continue his protest, to bring his protest to a broader sphere. So we took the show on the road and went to D.C. And spent nothing but rolls of sticker quarters for gas, food, and lodging the entire way. That is amazing. That is amazing. I love that the coin collector types put things into circulation to make a point.
我的意思是，他就像是，这里有相当多的奉献精神。但他并没有把它们全部还给银行。就像，他也会用它们来继续他的抗议，把他的抗议带到更广阔的领域。所以我们带着节目上路，去了华盛顿特区。一路上只用贴了贴纸的硬币卷来支付汽油、食物和住宿。这太神奇了。这太神奇了。我喜欢这些硬币收藏家把东西投入流通来表达观点的方式。
Totally. I agree. I had to double down and clarify this with him. Like, hold on nothing but quarters. You paid for your hotel room in quarters, not once, but every night and gas. Wow. And also, they didn't just do that. When they got to D.C., they rolled this giant four-foot diameter foam quarter with his design from the White House to the U.S. Mint.
完全同意。我不得不再次确认并澄清这一点。等等，只有硬币。你用硬币支付了酒店房费，不是一次，而是每天晚上，还有汽油。哇。而且，他们不仅做了这些。当他们到达华盛顿特区时，他们把这个巨大的四英尺直径的泡沫硬币，上面印着他的设计，从白宫滚到了美国铸币局。
And the press did love this. An artist from Columbia, Missouri, is upset that the U.S. Mint has rejected his design for the state quarter. He's protesting by putting stickers with his design on the back of real quarters. Today he'll be handing out those sticker-covered quarters in front of the U.S. Treasury Building here in Washington. This is such a fucking NPR story. Just the straight read. I love it. I mean, it's just a fat, slow pitch down the middle for NPR. And for us, here we are.
媒体确实喜欢这个。一位来自密苏里州哥伦比亚市的艺术家对美国铸币局拒绝他的州纪念币设计感到不满。他通过在真实硬币背面贴上带有他设计的贴纸来进行抗议。今天，他将在华盛顿的美国财政部大楼前分发那些贴满贴纸的硬币。这真是一个该死的NPR故事。就是那种直白的叙述。我喜欢它。我的意思是，这对于NPR来说简直是一个又肥又慢的投球。对于我们来说，我们就在这里。
But he mentions, like, that the Secret Service was investigating him. So this is like a question of defacing money. Like, is this something that he could actually get in trouble for? Okay, so he says he went to the Secret Service headquarters. We tried to turn ourselves in, and apparently the Secret Service doesn't listen to NPR or something. But they said, we don't have any record of you get out of our building. I love it. It's like, arrest me.
但他提到，特勤局正在调查他。所以这是一个关于损毁货币的问题。这真的是他会惹上麻烦的事情吗？好的，所以他说他去了特勤局总部。我们试图自首，显然特勤局不听NPR的节目或者别的什么。但他们说，我们没有任何关于你的记录，离开我们的大楼。我喜欢这个。就像是，逮捕我吧。
I love that he's just trying to be, you know, he's just trying to provoke them to have something happen just so we can kick up enough dust to make this a thing. Yeah, I think he's got a real sense of story and drama. Oh, absolutely. But ultimately, the type of defacing money that he was doing, it's not illegal. He's not trying to profit from it. So, you know, it's just legally not an issue. And so did any of this, I mean, you showed me the final quarter. So I know Paul didn't get, you know, most of his original design back on the quarter.
我喜欢他只是试图，你知道，他只是试图挑衅他们，让事情发生，这样我们就能激起足够的尘土，让这成为一件事。是的，我认为他有一种真正的故事感和戏剧感。哦，当然。但最终，他所做的那种损毁货币的行为，并不违法。他并没有试图从中获利。所以，你知道，这在法律上根本不是问题。那么，这一切，我的意思是，你给我看了最终的硬币。所以我知道保罗并没有让他的大部分原始设计回到硬币上。
But did his protests ultimately have any influence on the design process? Yeah, I mean, it was like this whole hubbub. And so the mint did keep offering redesigns. But, you know, Paul just was never really happy with what they did. And the whole thing left a bit of a bitter taste in his mouth. I divested of my coin collection during this entire process because I learned that basically I was the savings account for the U.S. Mint. They anticipate that you will take sets of those state quarters out of circulation. Plus the $60,000 with the quarters that he bought to add his painting to the back of.
但他的抗议最终对设计过程有什么影响吗？是的，我的意思是，这就像是一场骚动。所以铸币局确实一直在提供重新设计方案。但是，你知道，保罗对他们所做的事情从来都不满意。整件事让他心里有点苦涩。我在整个过程中卖掉了我的硬币收藏，因为我了解到基本上我是美国铸币局的储蓄账户。他们预计你会把那些州纪念币从流通中取出。加上他买来把他的画贴在背面的那6万美元硬币。
So he created even more seniorage opportunities for the federal government through the quarter program without even probably intending. Right. Yeah. There's definitely a big irony here. And also just throughout this whole saga, he made the Missouri State Quarter and those stickered quarters really hot commodities. Like people definitely took them out of circulation. And that's a win for the Mint. So if it's like whether it's artist approved or not, the quarters did their job, at least in the eyes of the mint. Totally. Though Paul doesn't really think it's quite so black and white because I asked him about that. I asked him who won, him or the mint. Oh, I totally won.
所以他通过纪念币计划为联邦政府创造了更多的铸币税机会，甚至可能不是故意的。对。是的。这里绝对有一个巨大的讽刺。而且在整个传奇过程中，他让密苏里州州纪念币和那些贴了贴纸的硬币成为了非常热门的商品。就像人们肯定把它们从流通中取出来了。这对铸币局来说是一场胜利。所以，无论艺术家是否批准，这些硬币都完成了它们的工作，至少在铸币局眼中是这样。完全正确。虽然保罗并不认为事情非黑即白，因为我问过他这个问题。我问他谁赢了，他还是铸币局。哦，我完全赢了。
Are you kidding? I had a blast and they created more opportunities for me than they cost me. I really, I'm just part of the Paul fan club at this point. What a guy. What a guy. Thank you, Paul. Thank you for your diligence effort fighting for your coin. Well, Katie Thornton, thank you so much for this.
你在开玩笑吗？我玩得很开心，他们为我创造的机会比他们让我付出的代价多得多。我真的，我现在只是保罗粉丝俱乐部的成员。真是个家伙。真是个家伙。谢谢你，保罗。谢谢你为你的硬币而战的勤奋努力。好吧，凯蒂·桑顿，非常感谢你。
I had a great time making this episode with you. Thanks so much, Roman. Me too. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Katie Thornton and edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Kathy Too is our executive producer. Kurt Kolestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor.
和你一起制作这一集我玩得很开心。非常感谢，罗曼。我也是。本周的《99%无形》由凯蒂·桑顿报道，乔·罗森伯格编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，天鹅现实乐队配乐。事实核查由索娜·阿瓦基安完成。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。
The rest of the team includes Chris Perubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Don, Kelly Prime, Jurek, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. That 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·佩鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉什玛·唐、凯利·普莱姆、尤雷克、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%无形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有一个链接，以及《99%无形》的每一集往期节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。